écoutez samia maktouf avocate de
victimes d'attentats terroristes elle
rappelle que de nombreux instigateurs de
ces attentats ne seront jamais jugés une
blessure pour les victimes écoute il a
fallu attendre cinq langues deux années
pour que les victimes et partie civile
puisse avoir un procès assister à un
procès parmi les 14 accusés seul 11 se
rend dans le box d'un cas sur les onze
étaient en liberté
en revanche trois sont en fuite
ces trois là sont malheureusement pour
les parties civiles et la tante de la
vérité de la justice en fuite est très
certainement très probablement on aura
du mal pour ne pas dire un me sera
impossible de mettre la main sur eux et
je voudrais revenir sur le cas dans ce
non pas de la fratrie belhoucine qui
s'est enfui mais d'une des actrices les
plus importantes de ces deux attentats à
savoir hayat boumédiène la femme
religieuse de coulibaly qui
malheureusement a fui le territoire
français et que la france a raté une
chance et nuit de mettre la main sur
elle et dahra patrie parce qu'elle était
dans le camp des loges qui est ce qui
était surveillé à l'époque par la
coalition internationale et que la
france avait facilement la possibilité
de la rapatrier et de la faire
comparaître dans le box des accusés lors
de ce procès